oh my God a police chase ends in a
shootout after a suspect allegedly
steals a U-Haul truck and runs from
police crashing into multiple Vehicles
along the way
one vehicle now
Dallas Police released the body and dash
camera video on Friday stemming from a
July 25th incident near the Dallas Love
Field Airport at about 11 o'clock that
morning officers began following a
stolen U-Haul the driver was identified
as 41 year old Ryan Taylor
[Music]
they just turned on finesse
officials say when they first attempted
to pull Taylor over he intentionally
backed into a truck pushing it into a
nearby fire hydrant causing the airbags
to go off dash camera video shows the
officers follow Taylor as he drives off
[Music]
foreign
just turned Northbound on post Taylor
leaves what appears to be a residential
neighborhood and enters the Dallas North
Tollway
[Music]
that's when video first captures Taylor
crashed into several other vehicles as
he attempts to outrun police
[Music]
thank you
as the chase continues Taylor Rams into
nearby Vehicles along the tollway
[Music]
number five
foreign
[Music]
oh
has been updated
[Music]
no it just kind of stayed back a little
bit yeah
[Music]
he's still going Southbound on
Dancing Yeah somebody can give me that
plate so I can put the registration info
on there
oh
we need another private homeboy of what
kind of vehicles sir
foreign
[Music]
eventually Taylor approaches an exit
officers follow we're in the activity
for Wycliffe
just took the Wycliffe exit
I'm Westbound at 2500 whitecliffe
dash camera video then shows the U-Haul
narrowly Miss hitting a speeding bus
oh my God five minutes later the chase
is still ongoing only coming to a stop
after Taylor crashes the U-Haul after
hitting a handful of more vehicles
let's get somebody check them out
video then shows a responding officer
Keenan Craven jumped out of his squad
car and chase after Taylor on foot after
running into a nearby private airport
hangar
800 lemon is less address I got
[Applause]
officer Craven yells for Taylor to stop
where he is instead Taylor fires
multiple shots seconds later the officer
opens fire
police stop
officials say officer Craven shot Taylor
in the leg he can be heard calling for
Taylor to show his hands
shots fired
gone
shut the fucking God
show me your hands
show me your head he then calls for
Taylor to crawl forward and show his
hands
come out here come out here
call out here
man you're stopping
man you're stupid
put your arms out
good enough
do not move
yeah
please show me your hands
ready don't rush it
[Music]
where's the gun
behind him all right crawl forward
towards us
crawl towards us
keep coming after Taylor was taken into
custody he was taken to a nearby
hospital for treatment officials also
recovered a handgun from the scene that
had previously been reported missing
Taylor now faces multiple charges
including aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon and evading arrest in a
vehicle the officer involved shooting is
now under investigation by the Dallas
Police Special investigations unit
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie